I have a report
now, that they're
sending a new rover to Mars.
And we are responsible for doing
one thing, which is programming
the algorithm inside
the rover, which
checks if numbers are prime.
Because let's say our rover
is communicating using RSA,
it needs an algorithm inside
that can do a primality test.
Now, when you design a rover,
or anything to go into space,
you have to be very
efficient in every way.
So the components used
have to be very light,
the amount of power
every subsystem
it uses has to be minimal.
You have to be saving
energy and mass
at every point in
the design process.
So we have our work
cut out for us,
because we have to be able
to deal with numbers up
to this size, and it has
to do it with very fast.
So, if we give it a very small
input, let's say just 90,
it should be able to
calculate that almost as
fast as this entire number.
So as the input
grows, we don't want
to see any of this
noticeable slow down.
Now I want to analyze the user
questions, or the ideas users
have had, which
were really good,
from a mathematical standpoint.
We are checking if n
is prime or composite.
So given some number n, think
of the space of all possible n's
as, say, if n is 100, then
this space is 2 to 100.
And what our algorithm is doing
is it's searching this space.
OK.
So you can think of algorithms
as searching a space.
And at each point it's
asking-- think of it as a step,
a primitive step--
it's asking a question.
And it's actually a
composite test, the question.
So say, we're at number a.
We would say, in the
trial division method,
is n divided by a?
We just try this.
We drop a here, and
we try if n divides a.
And we see if the
remainder is 0,
which means is the divisor of n.
Then we can say, ah, we know
100% we raised the flag.
We're 100% sure its composite.
Otherwise, at each step,
we aren't quite sure.
It might be prime,
but we're not sure.
So we continue searching
until we hit the end.
And remember our wall,
in this case was,
at the square root of n.
That's if the worst
case situation
occurs when n is prime.
We search for all the way
to the square root of n.
And then we can say, ah, it is
prime and then we're 100% sure.
So in the case where n is even
a multiple of 2 prime-- so 7
times 7 equals 49-- if we
throw 49 into our algorithm,
the worst case occurs.
We go all the way until
the square root of n.
So the first set of
questions, from, for example,
the fourth dimension asks, once
we rule out 2 as not divisible,
then all multiple of
2 could be ruled out.
The same for 3, 4, 5, et cetera.
So that's a really great point.
Our old algorithm was
stepping along one at a time.
But we could be
using patterns we
know about composite numbers.
Such as, we know for
sure that if a number
is divisible by 2,
then its composite.
If it's greater than 2.
So 2 is prime.
But then we can say,
oh 4 is composite.
2 oh-- I missed 5 here.
Sorry about that.
4, 6, 8, 10.
And instead, we can take this
step like this, 3, 5, 7, 9.
So one category of
questions, they all
try to reduce this space.
So if we eliminate
all the even numbers,
now the checked space,
instead of being
up to the square root
of n, is the square root
of n divided by 2.
And we can find other
patterns in composite numbers
to try to make
this even smaller.
The other type of
question concerns the case
where we find a
composite witness.
That is we find an a that
allows us to say, oh,
we know n is composite.
Lola said, "Wouldn't
leaving the loop as soon
as we find prime
check equals false
cut down on some of the time?"
And yes, that's totally correct.
And it's something
we want to do.
As soon as we are searching
along using some step-- defined
by whatever pattern
we're using--
we find a composite witness,
that means it passes our test,
and we say 100% composite,
we should halt early.
We stop and say, oh, we're done.
We won't continue searching.
And this halting is great,
except it doesn't help us
in the worst case,
which is, if n is prime,
then the early
halting won't help us.
And now we can visualize
how these improvements allow
us to reduce the
space, thus preventing
as many checks happening inside
the computer, which, depending
on computer, will reduce
the amount of time it takes.
So now I can show
you the visualization
I've set up below, which
allows us to compare
two algorithms based
on how many steps
occur during their execution.
On the left is
algorithm a, which
is trial division, which checks
from 2 to the square root of n.
And on the right is
algorithm b, which
is, let's just say our
improved algorithm.
And in this case,
I've applied the check
if it's divisible by 2.
So we only do half
as many steps.
And I also terminate
early, in this algorithm b.
So it's not perfect.
I've just applied a
few user modifications,
so we can see what happens.
And now I'm going to just
play with this to show you it.
Here we can see as I
scroll, we see algorithm a.
We have the output, whether
it's composite or prime,
and at the bottom you'll
see the number of steps.
So the first thing to notice
is on the right-hand side,
every other number
takes only one step.
And we know why that
is, because if it's
an even number, such
as this, it will quit.
So our old algorithm
took 314 steps.
And our new algorithm
only took one step,
because it checked if
it was divisible by 2.
So that seems like a
really nice optimization.
However, as we build
our input, you'll
notice the steps increase.
And the bar grows and
turns red, once we approach
the region where
we're going to crash.
So this red line up
here is step limit.
If your bar hits
there, we fail, which
means our rover would break.
And in this case, the
browser will actually crash.
So I'll try to get close to it.
So I'm close to it now.
And it's running very slow.
I can feel that
my browser is just
about to crash and give
me the circle of death.
But notice that our improved
algorithm took only two steps
in that case.
But remember the worst case.
I have a few large prime
numbers saved here, for example.
We have to be able
to handle any case.
We don't know what we're
throwing at our algorithm.
So if I throw a large prime
at it, look what happens.
Algorithm b, as we
know, is taking half
as many times steps
in the worst case,
but it's still
taking in many steps
here, because it's
the worst case, right?
So we're getting close
to crashing here.
And this is not a
very long prime.
We're still way under 15 digits.
And when I put this
12-- I think this
is a 12 digit prime
into our algorithm,
let's see what happens.
It's lagging.
Maybe it's going to crash.
Look what happened.
Both algorithms
went way overboard.
So it didn't work.
Our improved algorithm
is not good enough yet.
But now that we have an
understanding of what we're
trying to improve,
which is number
of steps in the worst case.
And we also have
this cool tool, which
allows us to visualize
how fast it's growing.
How fast the number of steps
grows as our input grows.
And below, I'll explain
how I set this up.
So you can set up your
algorithm and compare it
with the base case, and see
how much better you can do.